>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Pam Jackson: So I'm Pam
Jackson, Director for Center
for the Book here at
the Library of Congress.
And I welcome you today.
We are part of the national
and international outreach unit
of the Library, and we're thrilled
to be a partner with you as part
of our Books and Beyond Series.
We are really excited
about the kinds of authors
and book talks we get to
have here at the Library.
And we welcome you to learn
more about Center for the Book,
the national and international
outreach, and the Library itself.
And I usually share --
and I will do so now --
that it is the Library's mission
to provide the American people
with a rich, diverse and
enduring source of knowledge.
And we care that that source be
something that is relied upon
by the American people to
inform, engage, and excite folks.
And to do so for a purpose.
And the purpose is to stimulate
intellectual and creative endeavors.
And it is the case that we are,
at the Library of Congress,
America's first cultural
institution.
And that is part of
what we see as our role.
Excuse me.
It's also part of our vision at the
Library that we're the chief steward
of the record of knowledge
for America and the world.
And in having that
record it allows us
to create futures beyond
imagination.
Today's author is a steward in his
own right as a recorder of knowledge
and history, and one who's
accomplished remarkable achievement.
And it's an honor to have you
here to discuss your work.
I'll mention that the
Center for the Book,
which includes the Young
Reader Center and the Poetry
and Literature Center, promotes
literacy and reading books,
libraries, poetry, and
literature for a purpose.
It is our statute.
We are enacted by law in Congress.
We do so, though, for the purpose
of creating engaging societies.
Engaged societies.
Informed and educated societies.
And because we believe that
books and literacy and reading
and libraries are the best weapons
against ignorance, intolerance.
And those are important weapons
in the war that we fight.
Now one of the things I'd
like to mention is that most
of us here take literacy
for granted.
And we want to encourage
folks to remember
that it actually is
almost a silent war.
So sometimes when I talk about
weapons in the war against ignorance
and intolerance, people
miss the point.
You hear kind of maybe a
political conversation.
There's a social one.
The Center for the Book
also administers the Library
of Congress Literacy Awards Program.
And our funder and sponsor is
David Rubinstein, who cares mostly
that people in America and across
the world get that literacy matters
and it's something
that is a critical
and essential part of our lives.
That most of us who are
literate take completely
for granted and miss.
And we have it as our mission
to promote the cause of literacy
and to have it be a loud,
proud part of who we are
as the Library of Congress.
So I share that with you today
to invite you to know that,
to visit our site at read.gov,
where we have a lot more information
about our programs and what we do,
reading promotion and
literacy promotion.
I can mention also that we are
part of a global conversation.
We have partners from as far away
as Afghanistan and Australia,
New Zealand, Cambodia, Brazil.
And most of those were with
us last month for an event.
So we're part of a
global conversation
about reading promotion
and literacy.
And I want you to have that
in mind as you sit here today.
It's a very intimate talk
about a particular book
from a particular man
who is brilliant.
And it's part of a
global conversation.
So let me mentioned before
I introduce our author
that we are recording the event,
so if you ask a question you are
on record with that webcast.
Please know that our webcasts are
also available online at read.gov,
and we have hundreds
of them of wide variety
and range of author talks too.
On subjects of many genres, a lot
of diversity for you to enjoy.
I should also mention today's book
is for sale in the back of the room,
so please make sure you take time
if you haven't already
to purchase a copy.
And that the author will
be available for signing.
Our chief criteria for this
talk for our book series is
that the work be associated with
or tied to the Library of Congress.
And so in particular,
in this case it's
that the author has used the
manuscripts and the collections
of the Library of Congress to
explore and do research that led
to the book that we're
discussing today, which is,
"Alexander Robey Shepherd: The Man
Who Built the Nation's Capital."
And it is by John Richardson.
This is a fascinating biography that
tells the story of a self-made man
who came of age in the Civil War
and made a fortune in the plumbing
and gas fitting business,
and led the fight
to establish the physical
infrastructure here
in the nation's capital.
John Richardson has
become -- its author --
has been a public servant
and has served 45 years
in the nonprofit world
in federal government.
And he's a graduate of
Williams College with an M.A.
from George Washington University,
and has a wide-ranging experience
as President of the American Near
East Refugee Aid and the Center
for Middle East Policy, and later
as a Central Intelligence
Agency officer.
He served in Pakistan, Jordan, and
Indonesia, among many other places.
And he also is the author of a
book, "The West Bank: A Portrait."
Let's welcome John Richardson.
[ Applause ]
>> John Richardson: Good afternoon.
Okay, right in front of me is this
sheet, which I will share with you.
Please repeat the question.
So if you ask a question and,
you know as they say in stores,
if you don't get a
receipt you get it free --
I think something to that effect.
In any event, that's not true here.
But remind me to repeat
the questions.
It's a great pleasure.
I'd like to thank Pam Jackson
and the Center for the Book,
Library of Congress and all
of you for coming out today.
Can you hear me alright, by the way?
Okay. First I will sing for my
supper and I will say categorically
that the Library of Congress was
of tremendous assistance to me
in researching this book over
altogether too many years.
Particularly, I made use
of the manuscript division;
the papers of Alexander
Robey Shepherd are there.
Also scads of other people
-- William Wilson Corcoran,
who was a very important figure
at the same time in Washington,
and no friend of Shepherd's after
they had some initial exchanges.
The Wilson papers and
lots of others;
and previous research back even
when I was in graduate school,
I used the manuscript division
-- it's tremendously helpful.
And also the -- what's it
called, Photography and?
>> Prints and Photographs.
>> Prints and Photographs Division
was extremely useful and helpful.
And the great thing is that most --
many of the photographs are online
and they are all in the public
domain, so you don't have
to fight the owners for publication
fees and all that kind of thing.
Anyhow, so thanks to the Library
of Congress; couldn't be happier
to be here with you all today.
Okay. "Alexander Robey Shepherd, the
Man Who Built the Nation's Capital."
This was an 1871 portrait by Henry
Ulke, a German-American portraitist,
well known, much sought
after in that time period.
This 1871, as I said, when
Shepherd was 36 years old,
just about to become the senior
person in the territorial government
of the District of Columbia --
I'll define these terms later on.
But he was at the height
of his powers.
He was a co-owner of the
Evening Star for several years.
In fact, right, you can see
-- you can see it, trust me --
just to the left of his left arm
is a copy of the Evening Star.
And so the portraitist
was sure to include that.
Alright, first what I'd like
to do is to talk a little bit
about Washington, D.C. roughly at
mid-century just to remind you;
many of you are quite familiar
with most of this if not all.
But it was a different
time entirely.
The District of course is, was,
and probably always will be
under the direct thumb of Congress;
Section 8 of the Constitution,
I just reviewed it last night.
It says, "Congress shall exercise
exclusive legislation for everything
to do with the District."
I mean, the D.C. City Council, they
can, you know, legalize marijuana;
they can do anything they want.
But Congress can always,
if it chooses,
veto or certainly modify
legislation.
The District of Columbia at that
time -- and this means really,
I'll just say roughly pre-Civil War.
In fact, up to Shepherd's
time -- it was not one city.
It was one District of Columbia,
but in 1846 as some of you may know,
the State of Virginia asked for
that chunk on the Virginia side
of the river, now Alexandria and
Arlington; they asked for it back.
They said, please give
it back to us.
And Congress, without batting
an eye said sure, take it.
Well, this was George
Washington's sacred creation,
this ten-mile square.
And Congress, I don't even
think they had any hearings.
And so they just said sure, take it.
And so Virginia got that piece back.
But the rest of what's
left of the District
of Columbia was three separate
legal and political jurisdictions.
One was sort of the core city,
south of now Florida
Avenue; then Boundary Street.
Washington City, it was run by a
corporation, had an elected mayor
and two houses -- one was
the Board of Aldermen,
then the Common Council, the
more popular of the two sections.
But that was for most of the
period I'm talking about now.
Of course the second part
of the District was
Georgetown; ditto, a corporation.
It had its own legislative
and tax-raising body.
Then the third piece of the
District was that great huge --
almost like a horse collar --
called Washington County
that was everything north
of Boundary Street going
from the far west all the way
around to the far southeast
of the District.
And all three sections competed with
each other for pennies from Congress
for filling potholes, for paving
streets, for doing things.
Because Congress had very
little interest in the District;
and I'll talk more about that.
Certainly the topography of
the District at the time,
and the man Don Hawkins,
who's a cartographer,
he's a wonderful historical
cartographer.
And he has created 3-D,
holographic, various kinds of maps
that have re-created the topography
of the district at the time.
Basically very hilly, up and
down creeks, valleys, hills.
Jenkins Hill, now Capitol Hill,
was the most prominent
structure, physical structure.
But it was -- and all of the
roads just followed the existing
topography; so it was
really up and down.
The part, sort of say from the
Capitol up to the White House,
that was pretty flat; it
was near the Potomac River.
But other parts of the District
were quite, quite hilly.
As I said, the child of
Congress; nothing was done
without Congress' approval.
And the city was really not
-- it wasn't much to look at.
John Kennedy, when he was
President he made a quip;
he said that Washington
was best known
for its northern charm
and southern efficiency.
A lot of people thought
that was pretty good.
Just before the Civil War,
the slave trade still existed.
I mean, slaves were -- the
slave trade was abolished
by the Compromise of 1850.
But slaves were owned and held
in the District of Columbia;
there were roughly some
3800 slaves at the time.
There were also 11,000 free
Blacks in the District at the time
of the Civil War, many of whom,
James Wormley and other figures --
he was a very known hotelier,
restauranteur and had
against all odds had
created lives and some status
for themselves and their families.
But it was not a -- it was always
-- anything until the Emancipation
and even thereafter was
very tough for Blacks.
The District competed for dollars
from this miserly Congress;
the members of Congress
did not think of Washington
as the national capital;
that's where the Congress met.
And their reference points were
their home districts or home states
if they were in the Senate.
And the boarding houses where they
lived when they came to Washington
for Congressional sessions.
But they -- and this is really
important to understand the mindset
at the time -- Congress did not
think it had any responsibilities
to take care of, to
maintain, to repair,
to build the District of Columbia.
The original plan way back,
1790, '91 was that land sales,
building lots would provide
somehow a pot of money
that then would be used for
roads and things like that.
But the lot sales, as
you I'm sure well know,
were a great failure,
a disappointment.
And no legislation was ever
implemented or instituted to provide
for maintaining the city.
And Congress more importantly,
perhaps even so,
did not think it had a
responsibility to do so.
And this was reflected always.
So Washington was a
pretty scruffy place
around the time of the Civil War.
A few public buildings, you know,
the patent office, the post office,
the White House, the Capitol.
But not a whole lot else.
And if you see photographs of that
period, you will see that picture
of Pennsylvania Avenue
was kind of low,
little one- or two-story buildings.
And then with the Treasury
Building at one end
and the Capitol at the other.
And also unpaved streets.
In fact, let's see what we've got.
Yes, this is F Street looking east;
this is the southern front of the --
of what is now the portrait
gallery of the American Art Museum.
And then this is the Masonic
Building, if any of you know that;
it's right at 9th and
F; it's still there,
it's a very handsome building.
And you can see -- above
all I wanted to show this --
it shows these were
the unpaved streets.
There was one paved street
basically in the district.
And that was between the
Capitol and the Treasury.
Most of the other streets, they
were mud and mess in the winter,
and they were dust and
mess in the summer.
And really not a good
way to get around.
This was just the -- now 14th Street
Bridge, of course Long Bridge, 1861,
showing the Maryland
Avenue start of the bridge
and looking over toward Alexandria.
But the Civil War was a huge
problem for the District.
Thousands and thousands of
soldiers who were bivouacked
and garrisoned here, put in
hospitals by the thousands.
Tens of thousands of
horses tore up the streets.
All the trees were cut down.
It was -- they were cut down
for firewood for the bakeries
in the basement of the Capitol and
for every other use of firewood;
they were cut down to
make parade grounds.
And of course there were
68 forts around the city;
they were cut down to
create fields of fire.
And the District, of course,
in 1861 was surrounded
by two slave-holding states.
It was this little tiny piece in the
middle with Maryland on the north
and Virginia on the south.
And as I said, Virginia
had retro-ceded that piece
of the District in 1846, and
it was for a very brief time,
Alexandria was in Confederate hands.
But the streets were
torn up by the horses.
Buildings -- public buildings
and other private buildings
were turned into hospitals.
It was a huge military camp.
And it pretty much made a mess of
the city throughout the Civil War.
But then come 1865 after the tragic
assassination of President Lincoln,
the country at a loss of
600,000 and more men and women,
mostly by illness and wounds
that could not be treated.
But more than 600,000
people died from that war.
And the nation, back
together again, bloody;
the South very unhappy they lost.
But the nation for the first time
in its history needed a
true national capital.
Not just a place where
Congress would meet
and where the President
lived in the White House,
but a true national capitol.
The expansion was going on toward
the west, the vistas opening
up for creating the transcontinental
nation that it was to become.
So enter my name, Alexander
Robey Shepherd.
Faint drum roll here.
This is just -- this is more
of the unpaved streets theme.
I don't know the street; if anybody
can spot it by the buildings here,
you're welcome to share
that with me.
This is a Library of Congress
picture, but showing troops marching
on yet another unpaved street
in the District of Columbia.
And then one of my
favorite shots, this.
What's the most interesting feature
of this picture showing
Union troops on the Mall?
The Washington Monument, that stump
over on the left-hand side was
the unfinished Washington --
the Washington Monument, not
finished until 1884 eventually.
But Alexander Robey Shepherd, born
into a solid middle-class family,
born at 12th and Maryland
Avenue Southwest approximately
where the Mandarin Hotel is
now, if you know where that is.
And there's a cut, a railroad
cut that runs through.
And if any of you say House of
Cards, there were a lot of speeded
up film showing trains
running through a cut.
Well, that's about where
Shepherd's house was.
The place has been gone for years;
the whole neighborhood
has been totally changed.
But his father ran a very
prosperous coal and lumbar business.
He had a wharf down at the river
end of Maryland Avenue Southwest.
He also had a lumber and coal
yard on the Washington Canal,
right where the National
Archives is now.
But the father, Alexander
Robey Shepherd Sr.,
died in 1845 as a young man.
There was money, but
it was scattered.
Money had been left in the will,
actually to help Shepherd start a
business; it would have translated
into about $4,000 in today's money.
Not a whole lot, but it was --
there was money in the family
but somehow the estate
was squandered, was lost.
And I've never been able
to find out exactly why.
But the family was
impoverished as a result.
Shepherd dropped out of school at
the age of 13; he never went beyond,
what's that, the seventh
grade or so?
He was the eldest of
several siblings,
went to work to support the family.
His mother ran a boarding house
for several years right near
what is now the FBI Building;
in fact even I think
on the same location.
But Shepherd -- let me fast
forward -- by the age of 34 in 1869,
he was the fourth wealthiest
Washingtonian.
He had joined the J. W. Thompson
Plumbing and Gas Fitting business.
J. W. Thompson, John Thompson was --
perhaps in some ways became a
substitute father to Shepherd.
He was well-to-do himself.
He supported Alexander
Shepherd who was a very --
he was a very intelligent,
formally not very schooled
but a very ambitious,
competent person.
And he went into the Thompson firm.
By 1865 had not only become
a partner but had bought
out John Thompson and
converted the firm into --
there were several
variations; Alex Shepherd
and Brothers, and various forms.
But it all was with
Shepherd's firm thereafter.
But certainly -- I mean, Shepherd's
achievements were extraordinary.
A colleague and supporter
later gave testimony in one
of two Congressional investigations
into D.C. affairs that said that --
he said that what a lot
of people didn't like was
that Shepherd was a
mechanic with brains.
And this -- and the snobs from
Georgetown, the cave-dwellers,
the antiques, these various
names that were used for them --
a lot of them were Democrats;
they were pro-Confederacy.
And most of them were
very anti-Shepherd.
Of course in Washington,
you think about it,
William Wilson Corcoran's -- it
was his father or even grandfather
who had sold bonds for the war, for
the Mexican War; it was his father.
And so old money in Washington
was usually what, a generation.
You didn't have to kind of mellow it
through a whole series
of generations.
And so -- but these people, the
wealthy older Washingtonians,
so-called, looked down on
Shepherd as being a parvenu.
Shepherd was a patriot.
In 1861 in April he volunteered
as soon as Lincoln put
out his call for 75,000 volunteers.
He joined a D.C. militia
called the National Rifles.
He did a 90-day enlistment.
And then was mustered
out in July of 1861.
He did join the Union troops who,
at the night of May 24, 1861,
went across Long Bridge --
you saw the picture of it --
to the Alexandria side where
they took over Alexandria
from a very sparsely-defended
Confederate picket group, really.
Then he came back in
the summer of 1861,
ran for the D.C. Common
Council on the so-called
"unconditional Union ticket."
He was always -- he considered
himself a Lincoln Republican.
He was -- and I won't go
into it in more detail,
but he was no social progressive
but he did follow the political
and social main points of
the Lincoln presidency,
including the emancipation
of the slaves,
and later the voting act for Blacks.
Within two years, by 1863,
Shepherd was the President
of the D.C. Common
Council at the age of 27.
I mean, this is a man with
a 7th-grade education.
He had become an excellent
writer, speaker,
a very aggressive political figure.
But also with great skills.
He learned the political game,
how you schmooze in Washington,
how you wine and dine members
of Congress and others.
You know, Perle Mesta, the great
hostess in the '50s and all said,
in Washington if you hang
a lamb chop out the window,
she said the whole city
will come to your door.
And so Shepherd understood
the importance of a good meal
for getting political support.
In the '60s, Shepherd was
now the boss at this --
had been the J.W. Thompson
Plumbing Firm.
But Shepherd really did
have a vision for the city,
and I want to emphasize this.
You know, I said -- I call him the
man who built the nation's capital.
But he had -- but before
the building was the idea.
And the idea was that the
city, now the national capital,
it desperately needed to have
an infrastructure, I mean,
so it could build into and become
that functioning national capital.
And the tripartite, the fragmented
governance of the city, the three --
Georgetown, Washington
City, Washington County --
this status of the city was
a major obstacle to any kind
of building of a national capital.
And so Shepherd in the 1860s
really followed a double track.
One track was building his
company and his fortune.
As I said, by 1869 he was the
fourth wealthiest Washingtonian
after William Corcoran, after George
Washington Riggs, and another man --
Hess, I think his name was.
And at the other hand, he was
building political support
for what would become
a consolidation,
a political consolidation
through legislation,
Congressional legislation
of the district
and what became the
territorial government.
But -- and I will touch on that.
Shepherd was no democrat,
small d. And he --
I think his instinct was autocratic.
He didn't -- he was no
supporter of votes for Blacks,
but on the other hand he was no
supporter of votes for Whites.
So he didn't want anybody to vote.
And in fact Shepherd called
for, advocated, lobbied for --
and his supporters did -- returning
to the original form of government
of the District which
was guess what?
Three Presidentially-appointed
commissioners.
George Washington appointed
the three commissioners
that ran the government for
several years before it was --
the form of government was changed.
And so Shepherd wanted an
un-elected three-person
Presidentially-appointed group
to run the affairs of the city.
He built in the late 1860s a
movement called the Citizens
Reform Movement.
Which resulted in legislation in
Congress that was passed in 1871
to create the territorial government
of the District of Columbia.
It was a brief three-year period of
territorial governance just like,
in many cases like the
western territory --
you think of the Ohio Territories.
I mean, all of the
western states started off
as territory governments;
or most of them did.
But what the territorial government
form did for the district,
it then -- and it had a
Presidentially-appointed governor,
Henry Cook, who was the
younger brother of J. Cook,
the financier whose 1873
Depression and failure
of his whole financial
caused a national depression
that damaged Shepherd
very badly personally.
But the territory government
had an appointed governor,
an appointed upper house,
and an elected lower house.
And this may be familiar
to Washington residents.
And a non-voting delegate
in Congress.
Sounding familiar, right?
And so there was limited
representational government.
But Shepherd, he had the
backing of the governor
who supported Shepherd's
role in what became the --
he became the Executive
Vice President
of the Board of Public Works.
And this became his platform for
building the city's infrastructure.
Shepherd in many ways --
not to close an analogy,
but in many ways was like, or I
should say not unlike Robert Moses
in New York City, New York State.
Who for years was the czar of
the parkways and the tunnels
and the bridges throughout
the state, the legislation
for which he had written himself
when he was Al Smith's right-hand
man in Albany for a number of years
when Al Smith was Governor
of the state.
And then Moses came to then later
occupy those key positions for most
of the parkway and bridge and tunnel
commissions; it was just amazing.
And Shepherd did much the same.
He worked through and
developed the legislation.
And then he ended up being the man
who implemented these projects.
And so the Board of Public Works
was able to arrange financing
in the amount of six
million dollars, right?
Six million dollars --
quite a sum for the time.
Vastly more than the
city had ever had,
let alone asked for from Congress.
Three million or so was in
bonds that were sold mainly
in Western Europe in
some of the states.
And about three million in taxes on
adjoining properties of people --
property owners who received water
and other services
through public piping.
But that was sort of the good news.
And the bad news, if you will,
was that Shepherd spent --
and no one seems quite
sure to this day --
roughly 18 to 20 million
dollars on public improvements.
And by the end of 1873, '74 --
I mean, the city was in chaos,
but I'll get to that -- but Shepherd
used this money aggressively.
His approach was to tear
everything up all at once.
He was going to build
the whole city.
And so it wasn't just a
neighborhood here or a street there
or an intersection
here or a park there.
I mean, he just tore everything up.
And -- but the -- in
the process of --
I mean, he started off with
the best of intentions.
You know, sound contracting
principles, careful documentation
of expenditures and all that.
And then as the pace
of things increased
and as money became more scarce
and as the confusion brought
on by Shepherd's own lack of any
understanding of city planning.
There was not a field
called "city planning"
at the time; this is the 1860s, 70s.
Many things, including the
techniques of paving, street paving.
All these things were in
a developmental stage.
But Shepherd knew what he had
learned from running a business.
And he applied these
principles and practices
as though he were still
running a business.
In some cases it was okay;
other cases it was not.
But so Shepherd, he tore up the --
as I said, the whole
downtown infrastructure.
The winter of 1871, '72 was
one of the coldest and earliest
and longest-lasting on record.
And there are a couple of
pictures that I will, let's see,
show you that will give you an idea.
This was Bleak House.
Not bleak at all but a very handsome
house in what is now Shepherd Park.
Torn down 1916.
This was the out-of-town house
that Shepherd built
for his family in 1868.
This was about 200 yards
east of where my wife
and I lived for some years.
This is the -- if you can see
it, at the top of the building
in the center of the photograph,
that says Alexander R.
Shepherd and Brothers, Inc.
; this was the building he
built for his plumbing company.
And this was the parade -- there was
a parade along Pennsylvania Avenue
right at the foot of the building.
It was at 9th and Pennsylvania
Northwest.
And the parade was for the --
to celebrate the wooden block,
successful completion of the wooden
block paving of Pennsylvania Avenue.
Because asphalt was just being
-- was in an experimental stage.
Concrete was experimental.
But the gurus of street paving said,
aha, wood block paving is the best;
it's smooth, it doesn't hurt
the horses, it's not noisy.
And so Pennsylvania Avenue was paved
with the finest new wood
block paving blocks.
Within three years, the
entire street had been torn
up because the blocks rotted
out, they were miserable,
they just -- it was a disaster.
But -- and this is I think key
to a lot of what Shepherd did.
He started things,
he got things going.
He got a lot of it wrong like
some of the paving things.
I mean, sewer lines
would sometimes be put --
watch me; would come
together like this.
Not quite, you know?
And then they're supposed
to be like this.
And one would be above the other.
I mean -- and they had to
be torn up and done again.
Some streets were paved
before the sewers were put in.
I mean, it was really quite --
it had to do with the pace of
infrastructure development.
But also the fact that contracts
were let to all kinds of people
who had no business
being in the business.
They, you know, they
were bakers or people
who ran a millinery
shop or something.
And they would get a contract
and they'd usually flip it
at some profit to themselves.
But they had no business
building streets and sewers.
And so an awful lot of the
work had to be re-done.
But the key thing was,
as Robert Moses later
on understood even better,
that once you start a project,
if the sewer doesn't quite work,
well alright, you don't, you know,
sod it over and say well, no sewer.
No, you fix the sewer.
And so Congress ended up paying.
And that's where a lot
of the expenditures came
from of Congress in later years.
Paying for replacing a
lot of this shabby work.
Anyhow, I won't go on
too much more about that.
But I'll say that there
were a couple of instances
where the results of Shepherd's
paving were quite noticeable.
This is just a photograph
of the certificate
of President Grant
appointing Shepherd
as the Governor of the District.
He was Governor for only nine
months, from September 1873
to June 1874 when Congress
cancelled territorial government
after $18 million expenditures;
the city was in an uproar.
This was the very handsome
residence that Shepherd built
at Connecticut Avenue and K
Street Northwest right exactly
where Farragut North Station is.
If you've gone down into Farragut
North Metro Station, that was --
you're going down into the
area that was the basement
of Alexander Shepherd's residence.
But a very handsome house
designed and built by Adolf Cluss,
who was a German-American
architect who built a lot
of really elegant buildings.
The Arts and Industries building
at the Smithsonian, Sumner School,
Franklin School and Franklin Square;
these were considered really
the top of the line buildings.
And he designed this --
he also designed one for
himself down the street.
This right -- my favorite
photograph of all.
This was one of the results of
Shepherd's grading operations.
Because as I said, the city was
naturally hilly and up and down.
And Shepherd level
graded the streets
for the first time in history.
And a lot of streets, guess what?
Came down; some were built up.
This is one that came
down about 20 feet.
Look at this, there's
a ladder that goes
up from street level
up to the front porch.
And the ladder is at least
as tall as the house is high.
And Shepherd was an equal
opportunity offender,
in the sense of offending people.
There were two senators -- one
from Delaware, one from I forget
where else, who had houses on
Mass Avenue at 15th Northwest.
And they came back after
a Congressional recess
and found their very
elegant houses perched --
not quite as dramatically
as this -- but up on cliffs.
And they had to build ladders
to get to their houses.
Other people came home
after a Congressional recess
and found their house down in a
gully and with this road soaring
over it that had been built up.
And so there was major confusion.
There were two major
investigations of Shepherd.
And I'll emphasize one point on
this, that they were extensive.
One in 1874, one in
1872 before that.
Every opponent of Shepherd with
any kind of a grief or any sort
of an allegation, they were all
public, they were all in the record.
But no personal corruption
was ever found for Shepherd
in all the research in the
District and in Mexico --
which I'll get to in just a minute.
There was -- no personal
corruption was ever found.
But in 1874, Congress cancelled
territorial government,
they basically fired Shepherd
and the whole territorial
administration.
And instituted temporarily
for four years
and then permanently
in 1878, guess what?
The three-person
Presidentially-appointed
commissioner government,
of the original form
of George Washington's government.
Shepherd was out of
a job, he was broke,
he declared personal
bankruptcy in 1876.
He needed a new career.
He was broke; he had gotten used
to being rich, not surprisingly.
And he -- this is just one
more street grading scene.
This is Duddington, the famous --
long torn down, but the famous home
of Daniel Carroll of Duddington;
this was their estate
right on Capitol Hill.
And you can see this is -- I
mean, this is the wall right --
I'm going right up
to the home itself.
And that massive cut in the
embankment was to create a new road.
Right, and then this was --
President Grant tried to --
he nominated Shepherd for one of
the three commissioner jobs in 1874,
but the Senate turned it down.
And this figure of Justice
in the doorway is saying,
well will have no more of this.
Because it shows Grant reaching
down to pick up a newspaper
that has the name Shepherd on it.
So there was a lot of
unhappiness with Shepherd.
He regained much of his reputation
later on, but not at that time.
So he was broke, he
was out of a job.
This -- 1880 he had found
a new course of action.
He raised money in New York to
buy a silver mine in Mexico.
He knew nothing about silver
mining; he had never been a miner.
Never -- he did go to Mexico
in 1879 for an inspection tour,
came back with stars in his eyes
about the prospects for this mine
in this little town called
Batopilas where he took his wife,
seven children, the youngest one 3
years old, the eldest 16 years old.
In 1880 they went down to this
town of Batopilas which is
in Chihuahua State in the
western Sierra Madre Mountains,
Copper Canyon; it's
in Copper Canyon.
You can't get there by being lost;
you have to know where you're going.
It's like Theseus and the
Minotaur; and with a string,
you have to have a string to find
your way in and find your way out.
I spent about 11 days
down there in 2011.
It's a wonderful story, but
the mountains come down --
and you'll see some pictures here.
Anyhow, so I'm shifting
over to Mexico.
This was what they
called the Hacienda;
this was where they
lived and worked.
That's the guard tower to the
left, a very sturdy watch --
a front gate, administration
building.
Very elegant buildings;
they built all these.
And you couldn't -- everything
had to come in by mule
and down these zig-zag trails,
5,000 feet down into this narrow
river valley at the very bottom.
This is a photograph, that bridge
across the river was built
by Shepherd about 1893.
It's the bridge across
the river to this day.
He built an aqueduct on the right
along the lower bank of the river,
brought water down three miles,
drove a hydroelectric transformer.
Brought electricity to Batopilas.
It was said that Batopilas
was the second city in Mexico
after Mexico City to
have electricity.
I mean, Shepherd was just --
he was a man in some
ways ahead of his time.
This was a photograph of the main --
of the whole silver mining
operation administration building
with the crenelated towers there.
The watchtower would be just in
the far left of the building.
Shepherd, the boss,
admiring his operation
from a probably somewhat
overburdened horse there.
This is more -- just
another shot of it,
of the main administration building.
Silver ingots, they took these out
periodically by what they called
"conductas" [assumed]; these
were mule and burro trains,
highly efficiently organized that
went up over the mountain and up
to the city of Chihuahua,
where they were then shipped
on to the United States.
The family, the Shepherd
family in Batopilas.
You know, you saw that
elegant mansion at Connecticut
and K. They lived there in a --
it was a one-story
L-shaped adobe building,
which actually was the same
almost exactly as the predecessor,
the earlier owner of the mines
had lived in with his family.
I mean, it was a very simple -- not
prim, but a very simple operation.
Mrs. Shepherd gushed
at one point about --
she had been away in the States
for the summer and she came back
and they had whitewashed the
interior of their residence.
And she wrote glowingly
of this improvement.
I mean, so -- but Mrs.
Shepherd, God bless her,
was a real stand-by-your-man
kind of lady.
And -- but it wasn't the exotic life
that many people back here thought.
This is the administration
building today.
When the Mexican Revolution
destroyed the mining operation they
kept -- hung on for a few years.
And eventually closed
it by the late teens.
The villagers stripped
off the roofs;
they were very good quality roofs.
Once the roofs were stripped
off of all the buildings,
then it was adobe brick, and
the weather just took it down.
And this is the Alexander Shepherd
mausoleum in Rock Creek Cemetery
up by the old Soldiers' Home.
Has anybody been up there?
I'm just curious.
Okay, well several of you have.
Alright, it's a lovely old -- very
gracious old cemetery with lots
of Washington figures,
well-known figures interred there.
And several family members are
interred around the mausoleum.
Okay, just a couple
of quick comments
and then I'll turn it
over for questions.
What happened in Mexico
was, however,
is Shepherd's expectations
were never met.
He had planned to go down
there for about five years,
he said in his letter to his wife
when he was visiting
the mines in 1879.
He said, five years down here and
I can basically make it all back.
His intention was to come back
to Washington far wealthier
than he had been in Washington.
He was going to show
all the naysayers,
the people who were critical of the
chaos he'd brought to Washington.
But he did -- he had
built the infrastructure
of the city in three years.
And that permitted Washington
to become the great national
capital we know today.
But expectations were never met.
He came back in 1887,
partly to recover --
mainly to recover from a
near-fatal mine accident.
The people of Washington in October
of 1887 gave him a huge
parade -- huge; sorry.
A very large parade.
I truly apologize.
And so -- and I think people began
to appreciate more what he had done
and what an important
contribution he had made.
But I just want to close
with a couple of thoughts.
I've addressed the corruption issue;
I never found personal
corruption on Shepherd's part.
People around him made money; crony
capitalism, all kinds of things.
But Shepherd himself, he came out of
public service, public life in 1874,
territorial government ended.
He came out vastly
poorer than he went in.
Bankruptcy in 1876, I mean this
is not Boss Tweed up in New York
after whom his critics named or hung
that label around Shepherd's neck.
On the corruption thing, I
think he remained true --
and in Mexico he could have
embezzled from the company,
but he put all of his
own money back into it.
He was counting on rising in
stock prices to make him wealthy.
All kinds of issues, the
international silver market,
exchange rates, the crash of
1893, national crash U.S.,
all these things thwarted
the ambitions.
I do want to say, though, on
the sort of the assessment,
I personally feel that what he
did to build the infrastructure
of Washington was worth doing.
There was a major cost, and
I don't want to downplay it.
There is a book by Howard
Gillette, a former professor
at George Washington
University, wrote a book called,
"Between Justice and
Beauty" about Washington.
Justice being social justice
mainly for the Black residents.
Beauty being the monumental core,
the lovely city that really sort
of more formally came out of
the McMillan Plan in 1901.
But -- and Shepherd was
hands-down, he was for beauty;
he was for building the
elegant physical city.
He really didn't care very much
about the issue of social justice.
And I think that, and certainly
in his mind beauty certainly
triumphed over justice.
In any event, that's the story.
The book is for sale.
And I'll take any questions.
I apologize for perhaps having
gone longer than I might have.
And I will repeat the
question, alright?
Yes?
>> Speaker 1: I have two questions.
>> John Richardson: Quick, quick.
>> Speaker 1: One, it sounds like
he was at the height of his career
in 1873 here in Washington.
And I live on Capitol Hill.
Did he have anything to do with
the building of Eastern Market?
>> John Richardson: Well actually,
Cluss designed the Eastern Market,
which actually I think
was built about 1874.
Short answer is, he himself didn't;
I don't think he was
involved at all with the --
>> Speaker 1: So he wasn't
dealing with the plumbing
and the sewers in projects?
>> John Richardson: No, he
was doing infrastructure.
Sewers, water, trees, gas lights.
In particular, paving.
But the -- I think that
the Eastern Market --
and I'm sure you all know
more about it than I do.
But I think this was built by public
subscription and by other monies.
But Shepherd was not involved.
And the second question?
>> Speaker 1: And the
second question is,
you had made a reference of him
putting in thousands of trees.
>> John Richardson: Yes.
>> Speaker 1: Now,
there's no nurseries
out in Maryland to
provide the trees.
How did he do this?
>> John Richardson: Well,
okay, the question was,
how did he build the trees,
or where did they come from?
I mean, there were -- in 1960 I
worked for the highway department
of the District for a summer.
And there was right across the East
Capitol Street Bridge there was a --
the tree division had
its headquarters
and there was a small nursery there.
And so I think -- and
the B. F. Saul family,
the Saul family owned
vast orchards and farms
in Washington County just
north of Boundary Street.
So there was an awful
lot of undeveloped land
where they could plant
and grow trees.
Yes?
>> Speaker 2: A pair of questions
that relate to the grading.
What did they do with the fill?
Because some of it could clearly
have filled some of the bottom land.
>> John Richardson: Yes.
>> Speaker 2: The other thing is,
I had heard and read years ago
that there were something like
seven hills between the Capitol
and the bridge down there on
South Capitol Street [Inaudible]
and I heard a lot of that was
graded off and used as clay
to make the bricks in
building all the buildings.
>> John Richardson:
Well that's interesting.
>> Speaker 2: Was that
contemporaneous?
Was that earlier?
>> John Richardson: The question is,
what was done with the fill that --
when he was cutting down these
streets and making these --
putting these houses up on cliffs?
I mean, and awful lot
was used to fill
in the low spots; that's quite true.
And to be honest -- and
it's a good question --
I don't know where
all the fill went.
My hunch is that there
were plenty of ways to --
opportunities to level things
out literally and figuratively.
But as to -- my hunch
would have been,
is that you wouldn't
have found surface clay
that would have been
suitable for bricks.
I think usually -- I think of that
as being sub-surface
and you dig it up.
But I could be wrong about
that; others may know better.
But the fill got used; how's that?
Alright. Next.
Yes?
>> Speaker 3: I thought
one of your photos
of the unpaved streets
actually had automobiles on it.
>> John Richardson: No.
>> Speaker 3: So I'm
wondering how late did most
of the streets in D.C. get paved?
>> John Richardson:
That's a good question.
They were of course
paved and re-paved.
I mean that's one of
the unpaved streets;
that's just soldiers
marching; that's Civil War.
>> Speaker 3: And I can see a horse.
But there was a previous photo
where I didn't see any horses.
>> John Richardson: Well,
I mean, this is all horses
and carriages -- buggies.
Those are all buggies.
This is about 1867, I think.
>> Speaker 3: So there are
horses, I didn't see them.
>> John Richardson:
Oh, yes; no cars.
>> Speaker 3: When were
most of the streets paved?
>> John Richardson: Well, I mean
-- I think by probably by --
and a lot were re-done, I would
say probably by 1876 I would think
that they were paved and
re-paved quite adequately.
Because all the newspapers
were gushing
about this new
Newport-on-the-Potomac.
And, you know, people
could come down in winter
in Washington instead
of wintering in Newport.
>> Speaker 3: And do you mean the
streets south of Boundary Road?
Or streets north of
Boundary Road also?
>> John Richardson: Well,
Shepherd built out from the core;
he built out from the business core.
He was a businessman; he was going
to take care of business first.
But -- and he really slighted
Capitol Hill; trust me, that --
and developers and residents
of Capitol Hill just
howled to the moon.
Because he was focused on sort of
the Connecticut Avenue corridor,
White House up to DuPont
Circle; that's where --
and F Street, G Street,
11th, 12th, 13th, downtown.
But he -- and he moved out.
And he didn't get everything
paved in his time.
But I think it was all
graveled, it was all leveled
and graveled, if not paved.
>> Speaker 3: So you're talking
about streets below
Boundary Road, then?
>> John Richardson:
Yes, but he also --
he worked on the major
connector roads.
Georgia Avenue, 14th
Street, 7th Street Road
out toward Montgomery County;
because they were important
for bringing projects in
from Washington County.
Yes?
>> Speaker 4: He died
in Mexico, correct?
>> John Richardson: Yes; he died
-- but where did he die, and when?
Yes?
>> Speaker 4: Can you tell us --
I read that there was quite a
process to get the body back?
>> John Richardson: Mm, it
was pretty straightforward.
I mean, he died of a ruptured
appendix in 1902 at the age of 67.
Two company doctors -- he brought
Americans and internal experts
down to the mines for
professional jobs like engineers
and doctors in particular.
It just so happened that his four
daughters all married -- guess what?
Workers, doctors and
engineers at the mine.
That seemed to work out pretty well.
But he died of a ruptured
appendix in 1902.
He was interred in a family
plot up on a very steep hillside
above the Hacienda; I visited that.
But it was looted decades ago
during the Revolution, I'm sure,
Mexican Revolution, people hearing
about this fabulous of wealth
of Batopilas and Shepherd.
And so I'm sure that they
were looking for money,
but the sarcophagi are all smashed.
It was about a year later that his
body was brought back to Washington.
And then it was interred briefly
in the Crosby Noyes mausoleum.
The Noyes family owned the
Evening Star for generations.
And then in 1874 they
completed his mausoleum
and he was re-interred there.
Yes?
>> Speaker 5: Did he
live, if ever so briefly,
in Capitol Hill on Mass Avenue?
>> John Richardson: No; no.
He lived -- that's a good question.
He lived on 10th Street
for a number of years.
There is a photograph in
the book but not here of --
it was a very nice, standard but
large row house at 1125 10th Street.
And then he lived on, I think,
L Street at Connecticut
for a couple years.
And then about 1873 he completed
the mansion, Adolf Cluss's mansion
at Connecticut and K
and moved in there.
But then almost -- very soon
thereafter, 1876, he had to turn
over -- he didn't sell it, but
he turned it over to trustees
and it was involved in very
complicated legal processes.
But they always kept Bleak
House, even after his bankruptcy.
And then able to come back
to it in the summertimes,
and the family would stay there.
He never left, as I said,
left Batopilas only twice.
But the family came back for
schooling and health reasons
and many things in
the intervening years.
And then of course
he died in Mexico.
Yes? Either one.
>> Speaker 6: Even the pace at which
he was working from '71 to '73,
for three or four years, where
did he get all the workers?
Did he bring people in?
Or was there just a huge
population explosion?
>> John Richardson: Yes; I mean,
there were -- it's a good question.
There were -- certainly the -- I
mean, there were lots of workers.
There was a substantial
Irish-American population;
many laborers came from that group.
Many Blacks.
I think contractors I'm sure
brought in their own workers
from Maryland and Virginia.
The short answer is, I
don't know a lot about --
that's more in sort of the
social history side of it.
And I don't know as much about it.
But he -- there were issues about
salary scales and wages and all
that that I won't go into.
But let's just say
he found the workers.
Yes?
>> Speaker 7: I remember
reading that a lot of --
and you sort of alluded to the fact
that a lot of the development was
up around Conn Circle
and Mass Avenue,
all because he lived up there.
But is it the fact that the downtown
[Inaudible] I think I remember
like 7th Street being --
>> John Richardson: Oh yes;
it was a major artery; yes.
>> Speaker 7: [Inaudible]
all of that?
>> John Richardson: Yes.
No, I mean, there was --
this wasn't either/or.
I mean, he was this sort
of do-it-all-at-once;
he certainly favored that --
what I'll call sort of
that Northwest axis.
But downtown and the Northwest
axis were the main things.
Pam, I think you want to --
>> Pam Jackson: [Inaudible]
close out.
>> John Richardson:
Alright; one more?
>> Pam Jackson: One more.
>> John Richardson: One more, tada.
Yes, sir?
>> Speaker 8: Hi; Shepherd is
remembered today for the heart
of Washington D.C., upper 16th
Street, Shepherd Park neighborhood,
elementary school, etcetera.
>> John Richardson: Oh, yes; yes.
Yes, I lived there; yes.
>> Speaker 8: Why was
that area picked?
>> John Richardson: Well, because
you saw the picture of Bleak House.
Bleak House was part of a
230-acre piece of ground
that Shepherd bought in 1867.
And then they built Bleak
House and they used it as sort
of an out-of-town residence.
But that -- so that's why
-- and there was a long,
winding road that went out to a
guard house or a porter's house.
In fact, if any of you know
James Goode's, "Capital Losses,"
a wonderful book showing
buildings that no longer exist
in Washington and what is there now.
And it shows the porter's
lodge at 7th Street Road.
But that, anyhow -- so Bleak House
was part of that 200-acre piece
of ground where they built it,
north of Walter Reed Hospital.
And I lived there for 15 years,
very close to Bleak House.
Okay, I think, Pam, you want
-- alright; thank you all.
[ Applause ]
>> Pam Jackson: So yes, we
would like to say thanks so much
to John Richardson for
his book and his talk.
You certainly have made Mr.
Robey Shepherd come alive for us.
I took away from the talk that this
was a very fierce, determined man
who was committed to
make something happen.
Even if he bungled a little
bit, he was persevering.
So I like to take lessons
away from these folks.
So thank you very much.
And just to mention that
if you have more questions,
John has been generous enough to
be over here to sign his books,
which are still available
for sale in the back as well.
>> John Richardson: You can't
leave without buying the book.
>> Pam Jackson: Can't leave
without buying a book.
Matter of fact, he's going to lock
the door until you buy your books.
Let me also acknowledge the
Center for the Book staff.
We've got Ann Bonney and
Deziree Arnaiz with us today;
wave your hands and say hello.
For supporting and
planning this event
and helping us, so
thank you for that.
I can mention also that next month,
December 6th at noon we'll be
in Whittall with our
next author talk.
And the book, "Becoming Madison:
The Extraordinary Origins
of the Least Likely
Founding Father."
So we invite you back
to join us here at noon
in the Jefferson Building.
And last but not least,
thank you so much
for being with us this afternoon.
Take care, and have a great day.
>> Thank you very much.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.